how do you understand this when the
probability of a move is twenty percent
but the two-year yield is at point eight
percent markets Daria efficient it's not
always right I think this time they've
caught it wrong and I think we see a
rate rise tomorrow I think she's talked
herself into a position when she'll miss
her state and you know what the economy
if she says 25 basis points tomorrow us
strengthen the economy that's confidence
in the economy that's what the markets
need right now they need a bit of
confidence but a stability I think it
would do good to the markets have a rate
rise tomorrow what would it do to
markets overseas and economies overseas
oh yeah that's harder and I think your
point about China is really important
here as well does it give them space to
ease does it give the ECB space to
actually do more QE yes it probably does
and they need to do it they know that's
coming along and maybe it moves it
forward from later in the year to
slightly earlier in the year in November
or maybe october it's a fine fine run
thing about the decision tomorrow even
the number of people have been watching
blue book all day some yes some no and
you know whether whether the markets for
it or not and i think the conditions
right economically to go now it doesn't
go tonight she's worried about something
else she's worried about something else
what's gonna change it I worry about to
16 weeks was feeling a change but the
real concern has to do obviously with
global yields and if you take a look
into my Bloomberg terminal you have that
US 10-year the UK tenure and the German
tenure and they pretty much move in
tandem yeah the German you ten years a
little bit weaker but if we do see the
long end of the curve start to rise what
is that going to do for the global rate
environment so if we see right rides
tomorrow I think we get a rise up the
front end we've already see that that
with the two year in the last couple of
days pretty dramatic stuff 10-year yield
probably fairly static the long end the
30-year might get down a bit because
they're thinking about this path of
interest rates as they go up and
controlling inflation when it eventually
comes back round that's actually not a
bad thing for the long end of the US
Treasury market you may see mortgages
actually failing and change this might
be the biggest non event that we've been
talking about for a long time in terms
of the real economy but she needs to do
it she needs to signal the change in
direction certainly there is a real
economy effect as well to consider we
had the Bank of England come out with
its decision no
change there but the language that Mark
Carney gave was fairly interesting in
that they signaled they're really not
overly concerned by the developments in
China could that be an indicator of how
the fed positions itself well I don't
know how much they talk between Johnny
el embarque carne but I imagine there is
some chat and at the end of the day that
the job of both these central banks is a
domestic economy it the worried about
financial market stability that's
important and then clearly the
feedthrough effect on the economy is
important but you get your own economy
right you get the response right to
what's happening at home first and then
worry about everything else later and I
think it's a sensible attitude by Mark
Carney and it's one that Janet Yellen
should city take a very careful look at
if you're Mario Draghi are you able to
pump enough money into the system to
offset Fed rate hike a potential BOE
rate hike a global FX reserves that are
falling can you do it well Mario
Draghi's very very good at what close to
60 billion a month that were getting
already really good at verbal verbally
kind of supporting the markets as well
so I think he can and the the ECB's
increase its balance sheet by around two
and a half times during this
extraordinary period for monetary policy
fed you guys have increased it five
times you know there's scope here to be
to a lot more done I think it comes down
to how much the Germans will live with
the Bundys banks nervous enough about QE
anyway and there's a lot of chat with in
Germany and you know my boss is a German
and he's always worried about what the
ECB are going to do and I think that's
where the tension comes but there's room
for a lot more they yet before it really
becomes a problem has that has some that
anxiety died down though as a data show
that Europe is doing better after Mario
Draghi enacted QE I think the anxieties
around the legality of it rather than
it's around whether they should do it or
not and I agree with you ECB Q is having
a bigger impact a lot quicker than the
fed fed had when it started its random
policy easing extraordinary policy
easing by the way this is espoused to be
something that happens once in a blue
moon you've got to get out of it it's
another reason surely tomorrow so how do
you position yourself with this is
uncertainty and with the divergence of
this economic policy we're short the
front end of the curve in the US so
you're short two years kind of neutral
ten years
and we long 30 years so we're looking
for a flatter curve everywhere you will
shifting your risk assets so you're
putting more money to work in risk
assets of the moment I think if if rates
go tomorrow is that vote of confidence
I'd rather buy credit I'm quite happy
with with buying more high-yield credit
as well they're more riskier and a
high-yield credit but probably in Europe
I think the problems in the u.s. oil
marketer are well written about and
still here and I'd probably go over that
side of the pond rather than in the US
how about risk extending to of the
emerging markets what are you looking at
in terms of the opportunities outside of
Europe outside the US they're there but
you've got to be very very selective
about it you need to see that policy
response from China before you're going
to get really invested into emerging
markets in a big way from the from the
debt holders perspective we've got a
little bit in India now I think that's a
really interesting market that the
reforms coming through a strong and
you'll starting seeing improvement in
the sovereign that's worth that's worth
a good investment maybe around in
Indonesia as well some of the peripheral
countries around there you know those
places like Australia that are suffering
badly from China slow down that's a good
short right if you want to fund your
other investments I think that's a good
place to do it I last question here if
we do not get a rate hike from Janet
Yellen tomorrow what will markets do as
we've seen this rally over the last two
days I think it depends what she says it
245 the 230 statements are relevant and
if she puts rates apple doesn't put
rates up it's all about the statement at
2 45 if it's dovish it'll support if
it's hawkish I think it'll support
because it will talk about the
confidence but I think the risks around
that a really very very high name I
think the only thing you can know for
sure more volatility